Hello, welcome everyone.
I am Mike Salem and I'm here with CEO and founder of Catalia health,
Cory Kidd. Cory, How are you?
I'm doing well. Thanks.
Great. So Cory, can you tell me a little bit about Catalia health?
Sure. So Catalia health is a healthcare company.
It's about two-and-a-half years old.
We focus on chronic care management for patients.
Now, we happen to do that using an interactive robot and artificial intelligence,
so we have a solution that is focused on solving real challenges that patients have;
but doing that not for a small group of patients,
but something that can scale to a large number of patients.
Can you tell me a little bit about your background, please?
And how you got started in healthcare?
So I've been working in healthcare technology for about 20 years now.
I started off 20 years ago.
I was at Georgia Tech doing an undergrad degree in
computer science focused in - really on healthcare applications of that.
Ended up - actually, by the time I finished my undergrad degree,
being hired as research faculty.
Helped to build a research lab focused on what we now call aging in place.
So a lot of different technology in the home environment for people to
be able to live at home longer rather than move into
a nursing home or assisted living facility.
In 2001, when I went back to grad school,
ended up going to MIT to the Media Lab;
wanted to stay in that broad space of healthcare technology,
but start, you know, playing with the new fun, cutting-edge technology.
At that point, the idea of social robots or interactive robots was very new.
There'd been a few of them built at that point in time and I
thought they might have some promise in this space,
so ended up spending a couple of years doing some of the studies
around the basic psychology of interaction.
And what that lead into is now what I've been doing for the last 15,
16 years in seeing that okay, this works really well.
When we care about long term engagement with people,
there's this huge set of problems in healthcare that we need to solve around engagement;
let's put these two things together.
And so my work has iteratively, then,
applied that into new areas of
healthcare as we've continued to evolve and adapt the technology to support that.
Can you explain to me a little bit about
human/robot interaction and why it's important in robotics?
Sure. So - I mean, human/robot interaction as a field is pretty broadly defined.
You know, you've got robots and people interacting with one another.
In terms of, like, academic tradition,
it comes out the field most of human/computer interaction,
which in turn comes from psychology.
So for me, in a lot of the work I've done over the last 15,
16 years in human/robot interaction,
a lot of that comes back to how do we as people interact with one
another and what of that can we apply in the world of technology?
This particular technology typically takes a form that can look at us,
maybe talk to us, maybe roam around in our spaces.
So why do you feel that that's important that we
have technology that can kind of interact with
us and kind of work closely with us in building that bond between that technology?
I think it really depends on the application, right?
Obviously there was - as humans,
we built technology for a very long time.
It's something that we do.
And, you know, you've got a lot of technology now that is getting more and
more complex and doing things in the same physical spaces as us.
And so part of that means just moving around around us.
Many of these take the form of robots or some other automation, right?
So the word robot is not necessarily very clearly defined.
All right? So we can think about a lot of things that we
interact with today or that we imagine that
we're going to be interacting in the next few years or they're going to
share space with us and we need to know what that means, right?
When this stuff is, you know,
in our environments, in our offices,
in our homes, you know,
and other places where we're going to interact with it,
understanding how that's going to work so that
this technology is to our benefit and not our detriment is very important.
So that's a very broad thing, very deliberately,
in terms of, you know, how we think about this,
the kinds of things that we're building.
But I think that's a lot of what human/robot interaction as a field of study is about.
Right? Understanding how do we solve these problems in a way
that benefit us as humans in terms of using this technology.
What kind of studies are you aware of that have, kind of,
taken place in this area that really, kind of,
started to drive this movement,
that were kind of like a focal point that people started saying hey,
we really need to kind of, you know,
focus a lot more on this aspect of how people interface with machines and not necessarily
just that the machine is here and it's going to do a job and we
really don't care about how it ties in socially.
Right. So - I mean, there are thousands of
studies in human/robot interaction that have been done over
the last two decades and that really builds on
the field of human/computer interaction where you've got many,
many more studies going back for about a half a century now, probably even longer.
So - you know, it's a field that people have thought about for
a long time and there's a lot of different aspects to these studies.
Some of them are, you know,
very broad and trying to understand - you know,
you put robots into a particular environment,
how do people interact or react?
Some of them are very specific, right?
So getting down to some of the details.
You know, if we have a mobile robot,
say they can move around.
How close can it come to you and you're still comfortable, right?
So very similar to,
you know, interpersonal space.
We're a few feet apart right now, right?
This would be a bit different if we were in
there right up close - next to one another, right?
So you start to feel awkward when I get into your face,
the same kind of thing with robots.
Is it the same as with us?
Is, you know, six inches too close with a robot?
Definitely is. If, you know, we were talking six inches apart;
three feet, this feels about right.
Is it that the same with the robot? So you've got a whole range of things and you can
imagine all different aspects of interpersonal interaction with other people.
How do we apply those in the world of technology,
specifically in the world of robotics?
So there's this whole body of literature,
again, looking at the very broad things, right?
Robots in particular situations or how do they help us in
education or healthcare or entertainment to the very specific.
You know, if a robot does this particular action or says this thing or,
you know, makes this sound or - right?
These very specific pieces.
There are a lot of studies around that as well.
Now, doesn't mean that the field is done, right?
There's so much more that we have to understand for a couple of reasons.
One is, you know, there are
perhaps an infinite number of those types of questions that we can answer.
We can keep thinking of new ones;
but also, the technology is evolving.
If we look at what an interactive robot or a social robot is
today versus what it was five years ago or 10 years ago or 20 years ago,
the technology is very different,
its capabilities are different.
As we continue to develop new things,
whether that be the technology or the use cases for it,
then we need to keep exploring these interactions and again,
going back to how do we make this technology in a way that
benefits us as people and the users of it.
So looking at some of these studies that have been done from a psychological standpoint,
how would you conduct one of those types of studies?
Like, what would you find that would be useful information?
So for instance, I know you got close to my face a few
seconds ago and you're like, does this make you uncomfortable?
A great way to do it right.
And you know, for some people it does, for me personally,
I have a very small personal bubble so that doesn't bother me a whole lot.
I saw that look.
But in those situations, though,
there's generally a distance that people typically like to hold, right?
A lot of it is cultural, some of it is social,
some of it is just personal.
But how how would you go about setting up one of these studies?
What kind of studies like these are typically conducted when you're
trying to do some sort of research for human/robot interaction?
Are you trying to say well, a robot four feet away is okay;
robot two feet away, not so much.
Or a robot that's two feet away that's six feet tall,
I really don't like, but if it's only half-a-foot tall,
it doesn't really bother me a whole lot.
Sure. I mean, some of those questions are very specific, right?
And you can imagine how to design a study and, you know,
any particular study needs a design that's appropriate for it.
But as a rule of thumb,
again, I'd go back to psychology.
So when I was starting off doing my master's degree at the MIT Media Lab 16 years ago,
one of my mentors was the late Cliff Nass at Stanford.
And Cliff semi-jokingly would talk about his research methodology as this;
he'd say - so Cliff was an expert in human/computer interaction, right?
Later went on to do some work in robotics,
but he would say, you know,
go into the psychology section of a library, right?
I find a paper with a great study about two people
interacting with one another and I would take one of those people,
cross it out, put computer and steal it.
Right? And so we ended up publishing,
I don't know, possibly hundreds of studies,
a lot of different studies of human/computer interaction.
Now he was very clever, then,
about how he translated those into the world of people interacting with technology,
but in general, that's a great technique.
So some of those early studies that I was doing, you know,
more than a decade-and-a-half ago,
Cliff and I designed together,
really using that kind of methodology.
Okay. If there's this kind of a problem that you want to solve,
this kind of a thing you want to learn,
again, there's a great precedent in how do we as people interact with one another;
let's go borrow from that, right?
Let's learn what we've already used in, you know,
academic or research settings to understand how people are interacting
with one another and understand how we apply that with technology.
And so it's a great way to think about that.
Again, what we're building in terms of the technology is very new;
what we're creating in terms of the interactions is not.
We really want to leverage what we as people already innately
or naturally know what to do and how to do with other people,
but understand where the technology fits into that.
So when we talk about, kind of,
this human/robot interaction and this technology building,
this technology, obviously the idea of
prototyping and building the actual physical robot.
And there's a lot of work and a lot of studies that have
been done on how to build the robot.
Right.
So what are some of the things that you do
at Catalia Health when you were designing Mabu?
So - you know, in the early days of building, you know,
the application that we're doing in terms of what's going to interact with patients,
we didn't need the actual physical robot, right?
That could be built in parallel.
So we started testing things out with patients.
Now again, didn't have the robot yet,
so the very first robot we had was - you know those little blue recycling bins?
We took one of those, we turned it upside down,
put two googly eyes on it and taped
the tablet to it with some mock-up software running on it, right?
And went and put that in front of patients.
That was our first version.
Next version, we got much more advanced.
We took that and we put a Bluetooth speaker inside of it
and one of our writers was in the next room acting as the robot.
And these kind of interactions actually told us a lot because we could constrain
things in such a way that we were trying to solve particular challenges,
trying to think about how we would introduce this with people and what kind of
conversation should we have or we could constrain
what conversations we were having on our heads and see what people did.
We got - it was pretty amazing, you know,
you put this blue trash can down in front of someone, you know,
the first - like they're going to look at you like you're a little bit crazy,
but then you start having a conversation and they get right into it.
We've got videos of some of our early patient testers who were using this and,
you know, they start opening up after about 60,
90 seconds of talking to this, right?
Totally forget that it's a blue trash can sitting in front of them,
but getting right into what we were trying to get.
So you can achieve a lot with building very little hardware and software if you
want to think about the user experience and the user interaction side of building robots.
And so again, we were doing these in parallel, right?
Part of it's building the hardware because ultimately,
we want a product that we can put in front of a patient and have them interact with;
but we can start doing a lot of the design of that before - you know,
well before we have the actual robot.
So why do you think it was that if you could put just a blue trash can with
some googly eyes in front of people that they would
open up and kind of feel this connection?
What do you think it is about that that kind of triggers that?
Yeah. So - I mean, it's a great question and it comes down to, you know,
really what we focus on here at Catalia Health,
which is not so much the technology.
The technology is in support of the real problems that we're trying to solve,
which is how do we engage a patient,
keep them engaged for longer in their own healthcare.
And for us, that comes down to really three things.
So what we're building is the intersection of medicine; medical best practices.
So in a particular group of patients dealing with
a certain condition or disease and a certain treatment, what are the best practices?
Like, what do we need to be talking to those patients about?
What are the things that we follow up on with them?
Two is psychology. Really a few types of psychology,
so in particular, the psychology of relationships.
How do we as people create,
build up and maintain a relationship over time,
as well as some aspects of the psychology of
behavior change and a few other things that we draw from here.
And then ultimately, for us,
those are tied together with our artificial intelligence algorithms.
So that's how we're really generating a conversation in real time for that patient.
Now those first two, though,
don't require the AI algorithms
and those are the things that we can start testing right away.
Right? We know what kind of conversations we're going to build.
We may not be ready to deliver them purely through
software when we start doing our testing,
but we can create those conversations,
we can have those conversations with a patient.
And ultimately, those conversations that we have, you know,
using humans with our patients,
same as a doctor or a nurse is going to have,
that's what we want to be building into our technology, right?
So the technology is what ultimately gets us to the point where we can have
those conversations in a very scalable way
across tens or hundreds or thousands or millions of patients.
Having those conversations with, you know,
a speaker inside of an upside-down recycling bin
is a great way to start to get us there, right?
And really understanding the nature of that interaction because again,
for us, it really comes back to the psychology.
How do you actually engage that person?
It shouldn't matter whether it's a robot doing it or a person doing it.
Obviously there are some differences, right?
And that's the stuff that we've studied along
the way and many other people now have as well,
but the nature of those conversations,
you can deliver through many different means.
I think you've hit on something that's really kind of important when you talk about
robotics because a lot of people think when you're working with robots,
it's just tech, right?
It's the algorithms, it's the hardware, right?
And that's not the point typically of a robot.
And the point typically of a robot is to solve a problem in
an efficient way or in a way that's not achievable otherwise.
So doing what you've done,
in, kind of, focusing,
you're just saying this is the tech and the tech kind of just fits in, right?
It might not be the most - it doesn't need to be cutting edge,
it needs to be reliable and it needs to
work well in the situations that we need to test it in.
And then we can move forward to actually solving the bigger problem.
Exactly.
Which I think is great. Looking at
these interactions with this Bluetooth speaker under the bin,
I'm actually really kind of - it's kind of blowing my mind that
that's the actual approach that you went with your first prototype.
What kind of prototype, I guess,
did you bring to investors first of all and what was
the reaction once you brought it to investors, typically?
So - you know, we've talked to a lot of
different investors in the life of this company or,
you know, even starting before the company officially existed, right?
So started talking to investors about three years ago now.
And you know, those very early days, you know,
we didn't even have a trash can yet;
you know, it was really concept.
Raised money, you know,
initial angel money based on that, right?
Really, on the concept.
Now, you know, I should say in the background, you know,
before this, I built the first version
of this and deployed it with patients 10 years ago.
Sure.
So it's not like this was a brand new concept.
There's a lot of, you know,
academic and medical research behind how and why this is going to work.
But in terms of Catalia Health - and this company
raised the initial money before any prototype for hardware or software existed.
Now, the bulk of our first seed round came after we
had a prototype that started to look like what the real product does now.
So the more - you know, as with any company,
the more you get in terms of fidelity and closeness to a real product,
real customers, obviously, you know,
that makes a much easier story with investors.
And so for us, in the early days,
it was really about here's the problem that we're focused on solving;
here's the technology that we're going to be building;
here's why we, as a team,
are good to build that, right?
In part, because I have done this before - I built this kind of technology,
successfully delivered it to patients.
And here's where we think we're going and why we can get there on a certain timeline.
So that was a lot of that message in the early days of fundraising for Catalia Health.
How many iterations did it take you finally feel comfortable with your final product?
So in terms of the design of the physical thing
or the software or the interactions or which part of it?
Just from the physical - the physical robot, right?
Yeah.
'Cause you're trying to really focus on how a patient is going to engage with
this and it's very important that the patient doesn't feel weird.
Right.
Right? So how do you kind of go about - okay,
well, this is where we started, this was okay.
You know, obviously you had the blue trash can,
googly eyes, then a Bluetooth speaker.
Right? And then it slowly - it seems like it slowly kind of built up over time.
But there's a point where you say okay,
I have all the functioning components that I need,
but now I'm going to change the design
because the eye doesn't look quite right or the head isn't quite the right shape.
What kind of - how did you go about making those types of decisions?
Sure.
What kind of testing did you do,
like to a focus group?
And then do you feel that right now you're at a stable point with your prize?
With designing our Mabu robot for Catalia Health.
We actually did a very fast process of designing that actual robot, right?
So the really early early stuff in terms of,
you know, the trash can or, you know,
if you can see the cardboard things behind us here,
those were really for testing more the user experience,
not the actual design of the robot, right?
And we deliberately separated these things out.
The actual design of the robot from
beginning to end took us about four to five weeks. All right?
Now we went with, you know, IDEO,
a great design firm, worked with
their San Francisco studio a few blocks from where we are now.
So IDEO was actually one of the early investors in our company,
we were start-up in residence so we spent five months
working right in the middle of their studio.
The industrial design process for this robot was, like I said, about five weeks.
So we went in with, you know,
here is the design brief.
The first week or so was, you know,
coming up with all sorts of crazy ideas, right?
So taking that many different directions,
things that look, you know,
all different, you know,
designs and styles and, you know,
some things that might be an appliance,
some things that are like totally sci-fi,
some things that there's no way we could ever manufacture,
but starting off with just this ideation phase.
And from that, we started to narrow down.
So let's get rid of the things that are just like
totally weird and out there we don't think people would ever want.
Let's get rid of things that, you know,
maybe we could manufacture,
but it would cost just a whole lot of money and as a start-up,
that's just not a good thing.
And that left us, you know,
with a smaller set of things.
And we started putting those in front of people. All right?
So I wouldn't say it's, you know, particularly focus groups,
but going out to places where we could interact with our potential patient population.
So we help a lot of patients who tend to be older,
not necessarily; tend to be dealing with chronic diseases.
And so, you know, putting some of these designs in front of people.
Now at first, that was stuff on paper, right?
Drawings on the computer screen,
on paper, getting some quick feedback.
And we tried to really rapidly iterate and narrow in on what might work.
And so it's a combination of,
you know, feedback that we got from people,
but also my experience of building stuff like this for
the last 15 years by the time we were doing that design.
And so just an understanding, then,
of what people are going to react to.
So our design brief going into that was really simple.
One, this needs to have eyes because we know the power of this psychologically, right?
Something that actually looks at you and makes
eye contact while it's interacting is very important.
Two, we wanted a screen on it.
Speech technology is getting much better.
So this was - you know, a couple of years ago,
the Amazon Echo was out.
Today we have, you know, more devices like this from,
you know, Google and Apple and many other things that we can talk to.
It's definitely getting better, there's a lot more that you can do.
But in healthcare, we need to make sure that we're always very accurate.
So one of the things that we do on the robot is when she's speaking,
she's showing what she's saying on the screen.
I can respond by talking to her or pressing a button.
And sometimes we might want to say oh, hey,
do you remember when your doctor showed you how to whatever, right?
Can I show you that video again?
So to be able to do things like that.
So that was criteria number two.
And then point number three was we wanted
this roughly the size of a kitchen appliance, right?
Now, we could build something that's humanoid as big as you or me;
it's going to take up a lot of space in our home, right?
That's not great for a lot of people.
We could make this the size of a cell phone.
Right? Possible, given the technology,
it's going to get, you know, put behind the bookshelf or,
you know, tossed in the kitchen drawer.
People are going to forget about it too easily.
So it's kind of roughly the size.
And so, you know, with that set of criteria,
we were able to then hone in on some of these early designs to say okay,
here's the set of things that fit.
Now, okay, we actually like this from this one, this from this one,
let's put those together - and so just a very rapid iteration process.
You know, having a team of professional industrial designers who were
focused on this project and able to really quickly iterate let us go from,
you know, initial concept to basically what we have today in a period of about a month.
Was there any other design or talk about having the robot look more lifelike?
So, you know, looking lifelike in a robot can be good or bad.
And that's a matter of perspective and opinion, I think.
There are some parts of the world where people are really focused
on designing robots that might look very humanoid.
There's this concept called The Uncanny Valley that I'm sure you're familiar with and,
you know, we really don't want to fall into the bottom of The Uncanny Valley, right?
This thing just ends up looking very creepy.
Given what we're doing also,
again going back to, you know,
where we position ourselves as a company in healthcare,
we want to make sure we set up the right expectations.
So Uncanny Valley is often talked about as the look of this thing, right?
You don't want to look too humanoid,
but there are also a lot of other expectations that come out of that,
not just the appearance, but the overall interaction.
So for the same reason that we don't try to make this look like a person,
we don't make it sound like a person.
Right? Now we want a very intelligible voice,
so we have a computer-generated voice that's, you know,
easy to understand, but is not human-recorded speech.
And also, for similar reasons,
we don't have completely open-ended conversations with this.
The robot's always directing the conversation because we don't want to set up
expectations with our patients that this can just talk about anything, right?
You can just sit down and talk to it because then the expectations are too high.
So with that set of things,
that helps us to start make these decisions about,
you know, what this looks like,
how humanoid should it be.
If you look at our Mabu robot,
it's - you know, you're never going to confuse this for a person, right?
It's clearly yellow plastic or in the near future,
other colors as well.
It has human-like features;
it has eyes that are going to look at you.
Oh, let's see, there's a head on there,
but the rest of it's, you know, this squat body on a screen, right?
So it's not like this looks just like a human,
but enough of those features to really draw on the psychology of interaction, right?
Something looks at me,
I immediately look back.
So using those types of things in the design are very important,
but trying to make it look like a person;
one, it's going to lead to the wrong expectations and two, it's very expensive.
Building a product like that starts to
get really difficult to actually manufacture a scale.
For the same reason that you have the eyes that kind of look at you,
was there a conscious decision to not make a mouth that moves as well?
Because you do fall into that Uncanny Valley,
even though it would be more of a - like
a computer-synthesized or computer-generated voice?
That you were worried about the lips
or the mouth kind of sinking up to the words and making sure -
Yes. So it's a combination of things,
right? Doing that is really hard.
And you said it's one thing and two,
I challenge you to go find a robot out there
that has moving lips that actually looks good.
It always ends up being a little bit creepy.
Now, maybe there are some out there I haven't seen yet;
there's a lot of people working on stuff like this right now,
so it would be great if there is, but I think for what we're doing,
it doesn't necessarily add a lot of value to it.
People perceive this thing as talking to them even though the mouth is,
you know a smile line embedded in the plastic.
It's not like there's anything there that moves or even opens.
People have no problem talking to this and having a conversation.
And what I've seen is again,
many robots out there do have moving lips.
None of them, kind of,
crossed that threshold of not being creepy,
you're just wrong, right?
And it's - many of them are now good enough that it's not like,
ew, you know, that's weird,
but there is this disconnect. All right?
So Uncanny comes from Freud's "Unheimlich," right?
So this feeling that something is just not quite right.
And through a lot of the studies that I did more than a decade ago,
we found that many of the features that are not quite right like that,
people aren't necessarily going to say oh,
that's wrong and be able to point that out and say this is a problem.
But if you actually look at
their experience with this robot and you compare one versus another,
then in that underlying data about the psychology of the interaction,
you can see these very clear differences.
So part of it's just learning these lessons about what things work,
what things don't and then how do we apply those in the design of future robots.
Can you talk a little bit about the reaction that you received from patients when they,
you know, unbox their first Mabu and kind of work with it in their house?
Well, I think the reaction starts -
like the reactions that we care about start even before that.
So one of the things that we think about is how is this introduced to a patient.
It's not like suddenly this box shows up at the doorstep, right?
And they go oh, my God, there's a robot in here, right?
So the patient's going to be introduced to us in some way.
Right now that's either through their pharmacy,
if they're getting a certain prescription that this might come
with or in the near future,
patients who are going to be discharged from
the hospital might be getting one of these as well.
So a nurse is going to be telling them about it.
What's that language that we use right then?
How do we set up the expectations in the right way
and set up the relationship that we want this patient to have?
How they're going to benefit from it in a way that they believe that?
They believe this is a tool that is going to be
useful for them and something that they're going to benefit from.
So the initial thing that
we think about is what's the language in that first conversation.
Who's going to be delivering it to them and what should they be saying?
How do we talk about the benefits to a patient before they ever even see this thing?
So, you know, our patients get this box at home and
it's probably the first time they've received a robot in the mail.
And so maybe at first there's a little bit of confusion,
so we try to make things as clear as possible, right?
When they first open up the boxes,
a little one page instruction sheet and it gives the whole long list of instructions,
which is take it out of the box and plug it in. That's it.
Right? So really simple and having a focus on making this
really easy for someone to use is important,
given who we're shipping these to.
Some of our patients are going to be very tech
savvy and they've got a couple of computers and,
you know, their smartwatch and a cell phone or two.
Some of them we know have never owned a computer. Right?
So making it so that any one across this whole spectrum can use this is important.
And they plug it in and, you know,
of course it's essentially a computer or
a phone kind of thing in here so it's going to take a minute to boot up.
But as soon as it does, it looks at them, right?
Oh, hey, good to see you. Thanks for taking me out of that box.
Getting cramped in there.
And so we try to make a little bit humorous at first and of course,
we're reading the emotion on that person's face;
did they like this humor,
did they appreciate it or that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard, right?
So we want to know that so we can start adapting to them right away.
And so it's important for us to, you know,
create some delight in that person right away so that they like interacting with us.
And we want to bring a smile to their face.
And from there we go into more of the here's why I'm here.
I'm here to help you do with this condition that you're dealing with or,
you know, with this drug that you're taking.
And so making sure that, you know,
in those first few seconds and in
the first few minutes that we're really communicating to our patients,
you know, why this is something of value to them.
And by focusing on these things,
so making sure that this is something that's
a delightful experience to start and showing, you know,
me as a patient why this has value to me,
we get a very positive response from almost everyone that we've put these in front of.
So one of our challenges over running various trials over the last decade,
from the first hand-built version of this that I put in front of patients back in
2007 to the early versions of Mabu that we've been putting in front of patients now,
the challenge has been we give these to patients for - maybe it's half an hour,
maybe it's a few days, maybe it's a few months;
at the end of it, they won't give them back to us.
So I think it's a great challenge to have,
but it shows you what kind of reception these do have with patients who are using them.
And I think that's a lot because you're focusing on the underlying problem.
So you're really focused on
the person at the end of the day and not the technology itself.
I know we kind of talked about this a little bit earlier,
but it's really about how do we help people and not how do we build a cool robot.
Right? Look at all the bells and whistles that this has versus look at what I
can actually do for somebody based on what I've helped put together.
Right. So so we think about robotics as an enabling technology, not as an industry.
We don't think of this as a robotics company.
Right. The name of the company is not,
you know, Catalia Robotics, but Catalia Health.
We're a healthcare company.
You know, roughly half,
maybe a little under half of our employees have a technical background.
Right? We've also got nurses and psychologists and doctors and writers and overall,
we're solving a healthcare problem.
The technology just happens to help us do.
How do you ensure that your robot is
performing more or less ethically for the space that you're in?
So I know there's issues when you're dealing with healthcare,
when you're tracking people's health.
So I think there are two things that we think about here.
One is, you know,
we're building a new application
for a group of patients and we think of it as - an application,
for us, is really the intersection of, you know,
some disease state, some condition and some treatment.
So we're helping patients with a certain type of
cancer take this oral drug every day, for example.
Right? What do we want to be doing to benefit those patients?
And so part of that for us is let's look into the challenges for patients today.
What are the challenges that they have successfully staying on therapy?
How do we go about solving those?
And again, the technology, then,
is a piece that lets us do this not for one patient,
but for thousands, tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of patients.
And so that's really kind of a guiding principle here.
What are we doing to help this patient population better manage their own therapy and
get information back to their care team so that
those people can help manage that group of patients.
So that's that's one set of things and that's really the thing that
drives how we design everything that we do.
The other then is on the regulatory side, right?
If we look at where we fit in terms of the healthcare industry,
there are certain things that we can and can't
do in terms of what type of a device this is.
And the good thing about that is that's, you know,
a very well-developed field, right?
You have this big entity called FDA and there's a lot of
guidance from FDA that is not necessarily about robotics.
I can actually guarantee you that none of it is about robotics,
but it's still very applicable in terms of what we're actually doing with our patients,
the challenges and the problems that we're trying to solve for them.
All of this guidance and, you know,
the laws and the rules are very applicable to what we're doing,
so we can use that also as a reference for the types of things
we can and should and cannot and should not do with patients.
So if you were designing the robot
for it to work with the human outside of - let's say Mabu,
for instance - and just in general,
if you were somebody out there who was interested in building
the robot to kind of work alongside a human,
what would you suggest that that person do?
Well, I think that, you know, just like we've been talking
about in terms of the specifics of, you know,
Mabu and what we're doing, I can tell you,
the first thing is understanding what's the problem you're trying to solve.
Right? So the example I gave is okay,
we look at this patient population and understand what are the challenges today.
Same thing. That applies anywhere.
Any problem you're trying to solve,
understand what are the real challenges today.
So in other words, what that means is not start with the robot.
Okay? Here are the features that we want to build into this piece of technology,
this device, but let's look at the problem space that we're working in.
Let's understand, you know,
what we're doing or not doing,
what are the challenges that people actually have and try
to set up that question in such a way that,
you know, we get real answers, right?
In other words, we're not trying to project what we think we can or can't do onto that,
but actually try to get some answers from people about what's
happening and what are the real problems that need to be solved.
So I have a question for you, Cory.
So typically when I'm getting ready to build anything,
I end up doing research.
And my research always leads me down this rabbit hole,
where all of a sudden, I'm like well,
I just need to build something really quick to do X.
Right? Let's say for instance I want to build a robot, like a robot head.
Okay. Well, I just want to build a robot head really quick.
So I bet you I can do this with, like,
cardboard and maybe some toilet paper tubes and I'm probably okay.
But then I start doing some research and I start looking around and I say well,
actually, you know, Catalia Health has a great robot.
It's nice, it's made of plastic and it's got nice eyes that move and everything.
Maybe I should do something in plastic.
So now I start looking at 3D printers and then I say well,
you know, plastic is cheap,
maybe I can move over toward something that's a little bit more durable,
long term, like some metals.
Now I'm looking at learning how to use a CNC machine - and it just
kind of spirals forever and I just never get going.
What is your suggestion on how to just get started?
So you know, learning all those tools and, you know,
how to work with all those materials - great skill set to have.
Right? But what you've got to focus on is the problem that you're trying to solve.
So it's kind of a theme of this conversation that we've had here.
What is the real problem I want to solve?
Is it figuring out how big this thing should
be and cut a bunch of stuff out of paper, right?
One small, medium, large.
Is it deciding what degrees of freedom this has?
Toilet paper tubes and,
you know, other cardboard stuff.
Great way to start mocking that up.
Right? Next iteration, you know,
you add some servos to the cardboard.
I've built robots that way,
literally hobby servos and cardboard put
together and even some of the early studies that I've talked about,
in terms of the psychology of the interaction,
this is how those robots were built because solving those problems don't require a,
you know, commercially polished robot that I'm going to sell to a million people.
I think one of the challenges is focusing in on what's the real problem.
Now, we've talked about this today in terms of the context of, you know,
business and prototyping and a number of other aspects and I think this is
something that's really easy to get distracted from, right?
When you start talking about technology, it's always easy.
Okay. Let's do this one extra thing.
Or oh, wouldn't this be great to pull in here. Wait. Look at that.
Right? Like you're saying.
And put that in there.
The challenge for anyone building this stuff
is how do you make sure you maintain that focus.
So let's say now I have a robot that I've
built and I've finally gotten over this hurdle of,
you know, using cardboard,
toilet paper rolls or something like that and I
want to actually test my prototype in front of somebody,
but I'm a little reluctant.
I don't feel confident with my design.
What's the best way for me to kind of, you know,
overcome that and how would I go about setting up that kind of an environment?
So - you know, I think there's a few things to think about.
One is do it, you know,
as early and as often as possible.
Right? So having whatever you're building in front of people is really valuable.
And I think one thing you find what you're
doing that is it's actually a lot easier than you
think in terms of getting people to interact with stuff.
Now, it depends a lot of what you're trying to build, all right?
If you're building stuff like we are in healthcare,
then I'm looking for a certain patient population to do it.
If I'm building something for entertainment or
a toy or that a lot of people would use, you know,
go to your family or friends,
whomever you can, you know,
kind of get for five minutes to interact with this as early as possible, right?
From the mock-up stage to every iteration of your prototype,
put this in front of people.
And understand what it is you're trying to get feedback on.
Like if you want feedback on
this as a business and how you're going to sell a lot of these,
that's one type of question.
If it's okay, I have this thing that moves in this certain way,
how do people respond to that?
That's a very different type of question.
So one thing I see a lot - so I've taught courses in
human robot interaction at a few different schools is, you know,
students who are starting off on this early on are going to test this thing,
but without figuring out what the questions are.
If you think about kind of basics of science,
same thing applies here, right?
What's the question you're trying to ask?
What's the hypothesis? Set this up like a study, right?
Like an experiment. I want to learn this about this thing that I built.
Okay. That means I need to ask this question or
this question or I want to put this in front of a person and have it do this thing.
So be very clear on what you're trying to do.
And again, don't worry about the fidelity of your prototype.
What's the worst thing that can happen by putting it out too early?
Maybe you don't learn enough and you figure out okay,
here's the thing I need to refine or you can
go and you can spend months building this prototype that you think is
really elegant and you finally put it in front of people and you realize that one of
your base assumptions was wrong and then you go back and start all over.
And so - and that's why I always stress,
like, getting this out as early as possible.
When I've had students building things,
you know, in a semester-long class,
often the most advanced technology I will let them use is a Lego Mindstorms.
Right? Everything has to be simpler than that.
You should do the quickest prototype because
the feedback is more important in terms of what's the problem you're trying to
solve and how are people going to respond to this general concept before you even worry
about refining the actual hardware or software that goes into your robot.
All that stuff is very time-consuming,
but it's a whole lot easier when you know exactly
what you want to build and how people are going to respond to it.
So what are some of the major misconceptions that
you find when dealing with human/robot interaction
where a person tends to
believe something is going to occur with the robot, but really doesn't?
So I think the biggest thing is like at a cultural level,
there's, like, this concept that robots are scary, right?
People are not going to use this.
The reality is when we put these in front of people, they love it.
This thing is not scary.
You know, we're not building some big sci-fi robot,
you know, with lasers in its eyes.
It was a cute little thing about this big that says oh, hey,
how's it going and just has a simple conversation.
And so while again,
there might be this big conception that robots are scary things,
or technology that talks you about your healthcare are not good,
the on the ground reality,
when we put this in front of patients, they love it.
I think that's the biggest lesson.
And part of that just comes from
iteratively building and testing this with a lot of people over many years.
So obviously, being CEO of your own company has its own advantages.
Yes.
What's your favorite thing that you like to do for your job?
You know, it varies a lot in terms of,
you know, what I'm doing on a particular day, right?
As CEO of a small company,
I do a lot of different jobs and roles.
But for me, a lot of the really fun stuff comes back to the product that we're building.
So we can build new features,
not for the sake of technology,
but for the sake of, you know, benefiting a patient
and actually get those in front of people and see how they respond to it.
So when I see someone who, you know,
talks about this thing that we've built in the way that - you know,
we've had patients say oh,
I can't live without this, right?
That's exciting. They see value in this for them and
for their health and I love seeing that.
For students who are interested in investigating HRI,
what are some of the cutting edge areas that you see, kind of, developing right now?
So you know, I think the interesting thing that's
happening with robotics right now is a lot of
the core technologies have matured to the point where we can build real stuff.
And so what that means now is we don't have to think about this as a robotics industry,
but as using robotics to solve a lot of other problems.
And so I think many students who are interested in
robotics have other areas of interest as well. All right?
So if you think about Catalia Health at a really high level,
we're combining this technology,
robotics and AI, with the healthcare domain and a specific set of problems within there.
And I think we're starting to see a lot of those intersections.
And the very interesting companies that we're seeing come out that
leverage robotics as a technology are the ones not trying to build a robot platform,
but the ones who are trying to solve particular problems.
And so in some senses,
it's a very vague answer, right?
I'm not saying, you know, this area or that area,
but in some senses it's very concrete in
that the interesting stuff that we're going to see over the next few years and
the successful robotics companies are the ones who are solving
very domain-specific problems leveraging robotics technology.
And we're starting to see that pop up in a lot of different areas.
My interest for a long time has been in
healthcare so I'm most familiar with what's going on there,
but we're seeing this across healthcare.
There's a ton of these companies in education.
There is a lot in, like, entertainment and play and, you know,
with kids and - so many different applications of robotics,
but it's where those companies and those people are really focused on solving a -